اخبار الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه بايجاز
من جنوب لبنان اهلا بكم مع استمرار حصار
قوات الاحتلال لمجمع الشفاء في غزه قصف
اسرائيلي جديد للمجمع نتج عنه تدمير قسم
امراض القلب واستشهاد مرضى واطفال رضع
جراء توقف الاجهزه عن العمل ووزاره الصحه
تقول ان الاحتلال حول المجمع الطبي الى
ساحه حرب مفتوحه والامم المتح حده تشدد
على ضروره حمايه المدنيين ومنشات في
القطع ميدانيا كتائب القسام تعلن تدمير
ثلاث دبابات وناقله جند اسرائيليه وتحقيق
اصابات مباشره والجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن
مقتل خمسه من جنوده بينهم ضابط ليرتفع عدد
قتلاه منذ بدء المعركه البريه الى
43 وعلى الحدود الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه
اصابه سته اسرائيليين اثرى سقوط صاروخ
مضاد للدروع في مستوطنه
افيفيم في حصيله ضحايا الحرب الاسرائيليه
على القطاع لليوم
الس7 ارتفاع عدد الشهداء في القطاع الى
11100 شهيد بينهم 8000 طفل وامراه وفي
الضفه الغربيه اسرائيل تواصل تصعيد عمليات
الاقتحام بشكل يومي ليرتفع عدد الشهداء
الى
186 بين وصل عدد المعتقلين الى
معتقلا سياسيا وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي يشدد على ضروره اعاده احتلال
غزه واحياء الاستيطان واداره بايدن تطلب
توضيحا بشان حديث نتنياهو عن السيطره على
غزه بعد انتهاء الحرب ورئيس الوزراء
اللبناني نجيب مقاطي يقول ان حزب الله
يتصرف بوطنيه عاليه ويكشف للجزيره ان حته
وضعت خطه طوارئ في حال حصلت اي حرب في
لبنان الى
اللقاء